diot avant qu'on arrive et on l'a
entendu tu fais du style doha mme ça et
j'ai entendu dire que tu avais l'oreille
mais son père qui m'a dit ça il a l'oeil
droit qui m'a dit que ton père avait dit
ça sur les paires qu en s'effacer c'est
pas vraiment ça c'est autant de lennon
tu suis pas je parlerai absolue mais
c'est en rythme d'accord alors là tu vas
nous faire un truc on va faire un blind
test très rapide on joue également chez
blue est ce que tu peux nous faire déjà
un premier titre on va tout de suite
voir de quoi il s'agit vas-y fais 98,28
placé pour toi là c'est pour ôter pour
kelly kelly ça à lyon
luigi sera avec nous demain ce sera avec
nous demain pour la spéciale saint
valentin
[Musique]
pas
ouais
[Musique]
m
on dirait on dirait que tu arrives au
club la poche un cocktail d'accueil
alors est ce que tu peux nous faire le
truc pour kenny alors écoutez écoutez
les mettre la musique avec faut les
mettre à bas les enfants peuvent
travailler ensemble même si vous faites
un beau duo tout ça tu as quel âge tu as
15 ans à 15 ans c'est dingue et tu as
déjà plus grande qu'elle y aller oliva a
dit m
[Musique]
et
à
[Applaudissements]
m
à
elle a mangé des lèvres
[Musique]
oh
que ça
[Musique]
je suis content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avoir lu au style drame et voilà on a eu
un coup de coeur pour toi tu as fait
c'est de le dater de la télé direct on
fait juste que je demande un service
avant tutu lie au kindal est-ce qu'on
peut récupérer ça pour un plat tajine
pour benayoun avec la liberté à toulon
venait en aide spéciale kenji mardi tu
séverac de kenji andalouse aussi belle
que jalousent ça aux collants gitano
conduite à nous tous tu feras s'est
ouvert mardi
[Applaudissements]